foreign
[Music]
program contains the opinions of its
hosts and guests not those of this
network the opinions expressed are for
non-commercial informational purposes
only listeners are cautioned not to rely
on programmed content to treat or
prevent disease but are advised to
consult with a licensed health care
professional where they live for
diagnosis and treatment of disease
and now the super
super fear of medical truth Dr Joel
Wallach
hello and welcome to Dead Doctors Don't
Lie Dr Joel wallacher host a
veterinarian and physician and I'm here
for kids and baby boomers and seniors
who don't want to die it's 75.5 like
their parents and grandparents I'm here
for kids and baby boomers and seniors
who don't want to be sick and miserable
for the last 15 or 20 years of their
lives like their parents and
grandparents I did achieve the rank of
lieutenant colonel in the Air Force a
lot of people say I treat them like dogs
but they do seem to get better now if
you have a personal Health Challenge you
want to ask about if you want to ask
about a Health Challenge of a friend a
loved one a work mate or if you want to
talk about medical politics or the
home-based business opportunity give me
a call toll free one Triple Eight three
seven nine two five five two again as
toll-free one Triple Eight three seven
nine two five five two or you can get it
to us today on the direct line the
toll-free line 831-685
um 1080. again that's 831-685 1080. okay
it's the priority line excuse me not
toll-free it's a priority line and then
um uh I I have to say a few things about
this uh 27 year old pitcher left-handed
pitcher from the LA Angels uh 27 years
old he was found dead yesterday
um no uh um bad things in it for as far
as murder or anything like that ages
you're shruggling their shoulders don't
know why okay
um well I've done 1700 autopsies on kids
under the age of 10 who died of the same
thing this is called hypertrophic
cardiomyopathy heart disease hypertrophy
cardiometry heart disease and pigs is
called Mulberry heart disease okay the
same deficiency
and of course is very common in dogs and
calves and every vertebrae to you know
my my thesis which is in the Smithsonian
Institute
um uh where I did 20 000 autopsies
Seventeen thousands have changed over
454 species of animals and 3 000 humans
and then of course his project in kijan
China 1700 autopsy kids at age of 10
that died of the sudden heart death
and if they do a hair analysis on this
Tyler or skaggs's body okay do a hair
analysis just take hair from the back of
his nape of his neck and run it and see
ahead of severe
deficiency of selenium you need to get a
hold of the CDs dead athletes don't lie
and exercise without supplementation of
suicide those two CDs will kind of give
you the the Deep details here
get a hold of that book Rare Earth has
been cures read that and goes into
athletes and why they die early and then
go to chapter 11 where there's been
cures and look how to collect the hair
how to package it where to ship it to
two two three weeks later you get your
results back and it tells you how to
interpret the results this is a
unnecessary tragedy everybody who plays
Sports regardless if they're in the
Peewee League or the pop warner League
or grade school or junior high or high
school or University or the Olympics or
professionals any athlete okay at any
age needs to have a hair analysis uh two
or three times a year to make sure that
they're you know during their practices
and their seasons and so forth same way
with the military same way with anybody
who has autism and ADD and ADHD and
Suicidal Tendencies are violent and we
can prevent School shooters we can
prevent Mass murderers suicides all this
stuff is caused by the deficiency of a
mineral nutrient okay all the emotional
stuff is a different nutrient than the
heart stuff but they're both nutritional
deficiencies of minerals and so if you
supplement with these things we can end
all of this we can end all of this I'm
really really disappointed in the
medical system I'm really really
disappointed in the government that
nobody's paying attention I've been
screaming about this since the 1960s
since the 1960s we're talking over 50
years
I've been yelling about this and this is
just another example of why we need to
do these things okay right now anybody
who's seeing a psychologist or a
psychiatrist or getting counseling
because of behavioral problems they need
to get a hair analysis there's no other
test that will that will give you the
information about these deficiencies
okay so we need to do that and again the
book rarest man cures the CDs dead
athletes don't lie and exercise about
supplementation is a suicide I also want
to
um uh tell you about of course you can
take the health abandoned heart pack
we'll give you everything you need to
deal with these the healthy brand hard
pack one per 100 pounds of body weight
if you're exercising working hard and
sweating we also have a wonderful sports
drink to add to that a health abandoned
hard pack I would throw in the glucogel
vitamin D3 and the MSM of course to deal
with the joints and cartilage and
ligaments and tendons and connective
tissue
but I also throw in our rebound or
sports drink our sports drink rebound
has 100 nutrients including the
nutrients that will reduce the risk and
even prevent the sudden heart death okay
hypertrophic cardiopathy heart disease
disease
Mulberry heart disease this um
sports drink rebound has 100 nutrients
in it including extra amounts of this
one to help us protect our young
athletes or even older athletes like me
80 years old right people who run and
and exercise on machines and go to the
gym or exercise at home or just even
take a walk around the block
okay and so we really really really have
to go out of our way to do these things
because you know we put all in our car
prevent the engine from burning up human
beings wait until you burn up and have a
problem say maybe I should do something
okay so I keep encouraging people I keep
encouraging you get a hold of the
information
dead athletes don't lie
exercise no implementation of suicide
okay rare Earth's been cures and of
course rebound or sport strength
I drink about two three of those a day I
carry three 70 pound suitcases you know
I'm 80 years old I'm only 150 pounds
myself
and I had an injury a couple of months
ago and I'm like 95 healed
um and falling into a sinkhole up in
Canada most people my age would have
died by falling into that hole okay it
was a big fall lots of injury but
because I've been taking these nutrients
for 71 years twice a day
um I was able to survive and flourish
and recover
okay and you can do the same thing
contact your interview associate today
and ask for the book
there's been cures the CDs dead athletes
don't lie and exercise those
supplementation suicide we'll be back
the Dead Doctors Don't Lie after these
messages you're listening to Dead
Doctors Don't Lie on the zbs radio
network with your host Dr Joel Wallick
if you'd like to talk to Dr Wallach call
us on the priority line
831-685-1080 toll-free 888-379-2552
[Music]
if weight loss is your goal try
youngevity slender FX keto caramel
weight management bars and Shake
designed to enhance any low carbohydrate
or low glycemic diet by supplying the
energizing and filling protein dieters
need without unhealthy excess carbs a
keto diet known for its low carb intake
pushing the body to produce ketones from
fat
used as energy a state known as ketosis
by using fat not carbohydrates as fuel
in this metabolic State a keto diet
supports and promotes healthy weight
management for Optimal Health with this
system you should be able to lose one to
two pounds each day
so what are you waiting for start
helping people today with your own
home-based business in recent years
several studies have discovered the
healthy benefits of drinking coffee
youngevity has now taken it a step
further with an entire product line of
healthy coffees from youngevity's java
fit selection of top shelf Gourmet
coffees all javafit coffees are made
from 100 premium hand selected a rack of
a coffee beans grown in the finest
regions of Latin America carefully
roasted creating a delicious Rich
full-bodied flavor try javafit's
original roast a perfect blend of mellow
and smooth with just the right full body
depth to make an aromatic and enjoyable
cup of coffee traditional as well as
organic and fair trade options also
available in 30 count single cup or 24
count single pot packs contact your
local FDI youngevity distribute meter to
get job illusion coffees and don't
forget to ask about home-based business
opportunities
[Music]
we're back with Dead Doctors Don't line
the CBS radio network Dr Joel Wallach
here for young Tiffany 95 Crusade we do
have lines open get us on the direct
line okay the direct line it's
831-685-1080-831-685-1080 or toll-free
one Triple Eight three seven nine two
five five two again that's toll-free one
Triple Eight three seven nine two five
five two and we're gonna do the youngin
business as a business and we're growing
like crazy we need help if you need an
income stream you want the tax breaks of
billionaires you want to have a willable
asset you can work together with your
family and your kids and grandkids and
and cousins and Mom and Dad and you can
um then when you're time to go you can
leave it to them and your will it's a
willable asset uh be sure to
um contact you and give an associate and
ask for that trilogy books Let's play
doctor let's say herbal doctor passport
chromotherapy and learn how to deal with
over 900 different diseases nine hundred
different diseases using vitamins and
minerals and trace minerals and rare
earth amino acids fatty acids herbs and
aerobic therapy oils the trilogy books
Let's play doctor let's say herbal
doctor and passport to Roman therapy
okay Doug what Pearl's wisdom do you
have for us today well I thought we'd
talk about uh natural remedies for
chronic pain as I've got a story here
from natural news and it's headlined
best natural remedies for chronic pain
they say how holistic health
practitioners recommend natural ways to
deal with chronic pain and they
prescribe anti-inflammatory foods and
health supplements that naturally reduce
inflammation responsible severe for
severe pain
they say food is really medicine which
is something you've been saying for
years
they say inflammation is one of the
natural defenses of the body against
diseases but excess inflammation May
hasten their development further more
chronic inflammation is known to cause
chronic pain one of the natural ways to
manage severe pain involves adopting an
anti-inflammatory diet this diet often
gives a prescribed along with a physical
exercise Stress Management and
alternative medicines
Foods include in the anti-inflammatory
diet a very and depend on overall health
of the person and the severity of their
symptoms generally it includes whole
fruits and vegetables as well as
moderate amounts of chicken fish and
animal proteins and the
anti-inflammatory diet prohibits this
consumption of sugars corn rice and
wheat which are all foods that increase
inflammation
they go on to say health supplements to
support the anti-inflammatory diet
support the anti uh these foods are
healthy foods by taking Health
supplements supplements that contain
natural ingredients may help reduce
chronic pain turmeric a very effective
anti-inflammatory spice experts
prescribe minimum daily dose of 500
milligrams for for people plagued with
chronic back pain and joint pain getting
high levels of vitamin D also helps in
pain management vitamin D is an
essential nutrient that regulates the
immune system
fish oil contains plenty of omega-3
fatty acids like DHA and EPA these fatty
fatty acids contribute to the production
of
resolvins and a class of chemical
compounds that help alleviate severe
pain resolvins act on immune cells and
nerve cells and regulate inflammatory
signals to reduce pain a person
suffering from chronic pain should give
cannabis oil or CBD oil one of the main
cannaboid compounds found in cannabis
plant offers several health benefit
benefits including pain relief so there
you go CBD oil
oh absolutely and of course we have our
soothe it's a cream and a little pump
bottle
and uh it's just great for skin pain
itching all that kind of stuff sunburn
but if you have some deep bone pain I
like to add the trauma oil from
aromatherapy all division uh tromal
t-r-a-u-m-a is it's it says what it
means if you really have some deep deep
joint pain I had four or five drops of
that trauma oil to the soothe a half a
teaspoon mix up really good and apply it
to a joint and you'll get really deep
pain relief for oh hours and of course
uh you could we also have the CM cream
which is sealed mineral stoliate
um and of course we have the soft gel
capsules the
of the CM cream excuse me of the CM plus
soft Joe capsules and so there's we have
all this stuff to relieve discomfort and
uh whether it's in your skin or your
joints or you have headaches and all
this kind of stuff
and there's no need to suffer just
remember though pain is a symptom
as Doug said describe he's quite correct
pain is a symptom is not the disease and
so you have to deal with the
inflammation and of course I'd also get
a hold of the books Let's play doctor
let's play doctor get a hold of the book
Dead Doctors Don't Lie and
epigenetics and you'll get all the diets
and really great stuff stay away from
the bad stuff including fried foods
processed Meats oils and glutens wheat
boiling around oats
and we'll be back with Dead Doctors
Don't Lie after these messages
you're listening to Dead Doctors Don't
Lie on the zbs radio network with your
host Dr Joel Wallach if you'd like to
talk to Dr Wallach call between noon and
one Pacific at
831-685-1080 toll-free 888-379-2552
[Music]
thank you
if your doctor is telling you that you
can get all the nutrients you need to
stay healthy well that's just wrong Dr
Joel Wallach has identified 90 essential
nutrients that the human body needs to
thrive crops only need three nutrients
to thrive so where does your doctor
think the other 87 nutrients come from
they don't so if you're not
supplementing you're starving your body
youngevity's Beyond Tangy Tangerine will
get you a long way down the road to
getting those 90 essential nutrients
Beyond Tangy Tangerine contains
plant-derived minerals combined with
vitamins amino acids and other
beneficial nutrients Beyond Tangy
Tangerine is a balanced and complete
daily supplement so if you want to give
your body the nutrients it needs order
Beyond Tangy Tangerine today contact
your local youngevity associate to order
this product and don't forget to ask
about home-based business opportunities
imagine a rich decade in chocolate
that's actually good for you
youngevity's triple treat chocolate is
just that an antioxidant rich dark
chocolate complete with probiotics to
Aid in proper digestion this all-natural
product contains no preservatives and
for those with dietary restrictions it's
gluten-free dairy-free glycemic friendly
and kosher certified not only does
triple treat dark chocolate taste
fantastic it contains super antioxidant
blueberries to absorb free radicals with
an auric value of 16
936 per piece triple treat chocolate
also contains a proprietary blend of
probiotics with over 500 million live
healthy bacteria per 8 grams at the time
of manufacture with 80 percent reaching
the intestines which is much more than
most live culture yogurts if you'd like
to learn more about nutritional
supplementation call your local
youngevity associate and don't forget to
ask about home-based business
opportunities
you've listened to physician and
veterinarian Dr Joel Wallach helped many
people on the Dead Doctors Don't Buy
talk radio program you've also heard
hundreds of people tell how Dr Wallach
and youngevity products have changed
their lives if you're now convinced that
Dr Wallach is on to something and you
want to try youngevity's premium quality
products for yourself we can connect you
with a distributor that serves your
local area simply call our special
helpline voicemail at
313-444-3463 that's
313-444-3463 call right now and leave
your name telephone number or email
address and we'll see to it that the
right person contacts you shortly
remember the phone number
313-444-3463 that's
313-444-3463 call now to change your
life that's 313-444-3463
[Music]
we're back with Dead Doctors Don't line
the CBS radio network Dr Joel Wallach
here for young Jimmy 95 Crusade we do
have lines open you can call us on the
direct line okay it's
831-685-1080 the direct line
831-685-1080 or toll free one Triple
Eight three seven nine two five five two
again that's toll free one Triple Eight
three seven nine two five five two and
if you want to live with me well beyond
100 chronologically say 110 120 130 140
150 160 170 180 190 200 plus so being
biologically 30 40 50. and uh Aubry
degree the great Professor from England
who deals with human longevity says hey
there will be people A Thousand Years
from now who are live today there will
be a thousand years of age if they do
everything right he is he puts out seven
things okay so I want you to uh get a
hold of the book epigenetics The Death
of the genetic three disease
transmission get a hold of that CD a
stick of butter day keeps the doctor
away I want to get a hold of the book
immortality in the CD immortality
Forever Young and learn and of course
this is from the blue zones and the
National Geographic they say the top 20
longevity culture is 19 of the 20 or
third world cultures they don't have any
doctors or insurance or hospitals or
Pharmaceuticals or anything like that
and yet they have 40 times 100 we
Americans do they have 40 times 100
rules we do they have 100 or 250 of
their population we only have one per
ten thousand what are their secrets get
a hold of that book Rare Earth has been
cures
and get a hold of uh exercise
supplementation of suicide and don't
forget that DVD praise the Lord and pass
the 90. okay and let's see here I think
that's going to add 25 to 50 healthful
years to your life of course you got to
take that 90. okay let's see here uh
Doug let's go to callers all right let's
head to Minnesota and Deborah you're on
with Dr Wallach hello Deborah you're on
the air
hi hi Dr Love I have I have Meniere's
and I am on five of your products and
have been on for about four years but I
want to know if I need to be taking
something else sure okay how old are you
73 in let's see do you have any other
issues any high blood pressure diabetes
no do you have any arthritis or back
problems
no
osteoporosis
no okay do you have any ringing in the
ears kind of a tone like a
our wishing sounds whoosh whoosh
uh a little no ringing but sometimes a
wishing sound okay it comes and goes
okay well Meniere's disease okay it's
also called vertigo it's also called
wallex vertigo Charmaine are you there
I'm here yes okay uh Deborah how much do
you weigh how much do you weigh
okay now what what is what is Deborah's
problem here Charmaine she has
osteoporosis of the skull absolutely 100
no mistake about it you get an A plus
plus here what would you do for a lady
who's 73 years old 133 pounds no other
real issues but she does have the
wallach's vertigo AKA Meniere's disease
okay and she has the the tinnitus the
wishing sound okay
133 pounds what would you do for her
well for her issues I would suggest well
first of all gluten-free diet no oils
and no fried foods and then for her
issues I would suggest that she gets on
a healthy Bone and Joint pack and adds
to that for extra work
um the ultimate daily classic the MSM
and the pro-joint and vitamin D3 for
absorption
okay unity plus and of course you do
that and give us a call every couple of
weeks uh Deborah and we'll walk you
through this um in fact we're just
finishing up a book on the subject it's
so common but yeah you can look for for
great results here just following what
Char said and we'll be back with more
after these messages and that does open
a line if you'd like to talk to Dr
Wallach today call us toll-free
888-379-2552 that's Triple Eight three
seven nine two five five two lines open
[Music]
foreign
physician and veterinarian Dr Joel
Wallach helped many people on the Dead
Doctors Don't Buy talk radio program
you've also heard hundreds of people
tell how Dr Wallach and youngevity
products have changed their lives if
you're now convinced that Dr Wallach is
on to something and you want to try
youngevity's premium quality products
for yourself we can connect you with a
distributor that serves your local area
simply call our special helpline
voicemail at
313-444-3463 that's
313-444-3463 call right now and leave
your name telephone number or email
address and we'll see to it that the
right person contacts you shortly
remember the phone number
313-444-3463 that's
313-444-3463 call now to change your
life that's
313-444-3463 hi this is your host of
Dead Doctors Don't Lie if you're
interested in a colon cleanse blood
cleanse liver cleanse you know in the
classical herbal way you want to ask
your youngevity associate for Herbal
rainforest herbal rainforest has 16
herbs 16 cleansing herbs classic
cleansing herbs and 77 plant minerals
that's right and these are all organic
it doesn't get any better than that in
your busy day and you're around all
these toxins out there in your workplace
on the way home going to work in your
food in the air in the water you need
herbal rainforest I guarantee you it
will give you a cleanse you can control
the dose it's a liquid it tastes good it
doesn't get any better than this a colon
that's happy makes you happy nothing
better than a happy colon herbal
rainforest clean it out for more
information on this product or others
you've heard about on the Dead Doctors
Don't Lie radio program call your local
youngevity associate today and don't
forget to ask about home-based business
opportunities
greetings everyone Judy devilba's here
what do you think of when you hear the
words Tangy Tangerine well I think of
like a sweet Tangy tasting something
well what I'm referring to is the
ultimate Tangy Tangerine it's a
fantastic product it has everything you
need and a great benefit is it's very
very delicious it's very easy to drink
I've suggested it even to youngsters
even children like it even little guys
even little girls they come right into
my office their parents can't get them
to take those chewables and besides that
they're not as good as tangy tangerine
and I give them a little taste of that
and you know something they're pleased
as punch so if it's good for a child and
it tastes delicious why not you there's
no excuse not to take a vitamin when it
tastes as good as that does so how about
it Tangy Tangerine should be the answer
to all of your nutritional program
problems for more information or to
order call your youngevity distributor
today and don't forget to ask about
youngevity home-based business
opportunities
PBS radio network network network
[Music]
we're back with Jed Doctors Don't Lie on
the CBS radio network Dr Joel Wallach
here for young giving 95 Crusade we do
ham lines open you can call us on the
direct line the priority line eight
three one six eight five ten eighty
again the direct line the priority line
eight three one six eight five one zero
eight zero don't forget the toll-free
line one Triple Eight three seven nine
two five five two again that's one
Triple Eight three seven nine two five
five two and if you need to lose that 10
25 50 75 100 pounds or more contact
you're going to be Associated get a hold
of the book in the CD called Hell's
Kitchen the subtitle is the cause the
cause prevention cure obesity and also
discusses type 2 diabetes and the
metabolic syndrome you also want to get
a hold of the book energy crisis and
look into the keto dot of course
youngevity has the keto caramel shake
and the keto caramel meal bar two or
three meals a day should be a keto meal
and then obviously moderate amounts of
vegetables and uh like baked sweet
potatoes and and things like fish and
poultry and red meat and then one
healthy weight loss pack for 100 pounds
of body weight take those things
appropriate for your body weight and
you'll lose a half pound or two pounds a
day and the magic age will never gain
the weight back as long as you stay on
the 90s 60 minerals 16 vitamins 12
minutes Three fatty acids because being
overweight and obese has nothing to do
with eating too much or lack of exercise
it was a fall series 125 years we
followed that theory I mean we followed
it to the letter and that's why America
is the number one obese nation in the
world because we followed the wrong
Theory okay and so get a hold of your
young giving associate and let's lose
that weight half a pound two pounds a
day and never gain weight back okay Doug
let's go to Commerce all right let's
head to Minneapolis Minnesota and Paul
you're on with Dr Wallach
well Paul you're on the air
thank you for taking my call yes sir my
hair and I got my report back and I'm
low on one thing and high on two of
things okay wondering if you can help me
out so one is a germanium I'm low on
that
and I'm high on titanium and high on
Mali dendum molybdenum yeah we have
Melinda them there you go
okay are you in the high middle or are
you off off the top on the libdenum
and okay it's up to .011 some high
middle yeah hi mitt okay that's fine
yeah that's good okay these are all
essential nutrients okay and so it's one
of those things where
um I'm so happy that you did that and of
course you don't have any excess amounts
of uranium and and
um that sort of stuff uh and so that's a
good thing that's one of the nice things
about the hair analysis we provide is
that you also get an assessment of
where you're at with these things that
are really toxic and so you didn't
mention that so
um I think you're in good shape
how much do you weigh full
I am 188 I have osteoporosis of the
skull and low back pain and are those
two things uh connected they are
connected low back pain could be
degenerative disc disease it could be
due to osteoporosis or arthritis or the
vertebrae bone spurs of the vertebrae
and when you say you have as he
approaches to the skull do you have
ringing in the ears or vertigo okay uh
yeah tinnitus
okay FX yeah
okay and this is gonna be for our
greater listening audience here what
would you do for Paul here Charmaine
well oh 188 Pounds obviously clean them
with the diet but for those issues Iowa
get him on two healthy Bone and Joint
packs and then I would add to that the
MSM and the pro joint and vitamin D3 for
absorption good and what what could he
stick in his ear with a Q-tip that would
help him maybe relieve some of the
inflammation and reduce that tinnitus
you'll see I'm cream that comes with the
pack yep absolutely the same cream just
like a quarter of a teaspoon of that CM
cream uh take a Q-tip put it down in
your ears when you wake up in the
morning kind of in the middle of the day
maybe a half hour before lunch and again
a half hour before
bedtime and that will relieve a lot of
inflammation and swelling and a lot of
times even before you begin to heal your
osteoporosis of the skull you'll get
some relief of the tinnitus
keep us inform Paul he'll be you're
gonna be a great testimony for our
listeners
Char and I will be back after these
messages
and that does open a line if you'd like
to talk to Dr Wallach today call us on
the priority line
831-685-1080 toll-free
888-379-2552 lines open
[Music]
[Applause]
you've listed a physician and
veterinarian Dr Joel Wallach helped many
people on the Dead Doctors Don't Buy
talk radio program you've also heard
hundreds of people tell how Dr Wallach
and youngevity products have changed
their lives if you're now convinced that
Dr Wallach is on to something and you
want to try youngevity's premium quality
products for yourself we can connect you
with a distributor that serves your
local area simply call our special
helpline voicemail at
313-444-3463 that's
313-444-3463 call right now and leave
your name telephone number or email
address and we'll see to it that the
right person contacts you shortly
remember the phone number
313-44-3463 that's
313-444-3463 call now to change your
life that's
313-444-3463 I am Judy of vilbus here I
am speaking to you again I just wanted
to tell you that recently I started
drinking the way shakes again the
chocolate whey shake and you need to
remember the way Shake isn't just for
losing weight it's a fantastic place to
get your great protein and if you're
trying to gain weight you can take it
along with your meals and the best part
is if you want to just have a great
protein shake do like I do put it over
ice Stir It Up and you can sip on it for
20 minutes to an hour I do it every
single day I absolutely love it you need
to get back to it too it's really good
for you and it makes not fat but it
makes muscle after you work out and you
can also mix it up in a blender with an
egg and you have the most incredible
Health protein shake or mix it with a
little water Stir It Up and you have a
little pudding and who doesn't like
pudding for more information or to order
call your youngevity distributor today
and don't forget to ask about youngevity
home-based business opportunities
[Music]
we're back with Dead Doctors Don't line
the zbs radio network Dr Joel Wallach
care fuel activity 95 Crusade we do have
lines open give us a call on on the
direct line the priority line
831-685-1080 again the priority line
831-685-1080 or toll free one Triple
Eight three seven nine two five five two
again that's toll free one Triple Eight
three seven nine two five five two and
let's see here again we're looking for
help we are growing like crazy and so
we're looking for people who want to
become a young Duty associate contact or
younger associate and ask them for the
trilogy of books Let's play doctor let's
see herbal doctor past program of
therapy and learn how to deal with over
900 of diseases 900 different diseases
using vitamins and minerals and trace
minerals and rare earth
amino acids fatty acids herbs
aromatherapy also trilogy books Let's
play doctor let's say herbal doctor
password therapy if you never run a
business before your own or anybody
else's get a hold of that book Wall
Street for kids and learn how to be
profitable learn how to get the tax
breaks of billionaires learn how to get
the same benefits that employees get
from the big corporations they work for
you know paid vacation things like use
of a company car your youngevity company
can pay for your
monthly premiums for your health
insurance and your life insurance and
many many other things including the
cost of your supplement program
and then your youngevity business will
get the tax breaks associated with all
that all right let's see here Doug let's
go to college let's head to St Louis
Missouri and Tracy you're on with Dr
Wallach well Tracy you're on the air yes
hi Hi how are you doing okay yes
um hold on one second I have my paper
written down okay I was calling because
I have
um so much information
um so much joint pain stiffness
um I I do my own house cleaning business
and
um I you know do that about four or five
days a week and I work another job and
um okay they said I had degenerative
dicks uh disc disease in my back okay
that had osteopenio a little bit of low
bone density
so I was concerned about those things
what to take to help okay with my joints
and all this and then yeah do you have
any other issues high blood pressure
diabetes
uh no a thyroid
um
very low I took medicine years ago
lithium in the 90s and I knocked out my
thyroid okay all right so I'm on um I'm
on levothyroxine 88 milligrams right now
which is the best I've taken in a long
time that hasn't caused what do you
weigh when your body weight Tracy what's
your body weight
144 right now and how tall are you I get
about five four and a half five five I
gained weight since I um had a kind of
these issues just recently I'd put on
about seven pounds
all right um let's see here Charmaine
you there I'm here
now you've seen this a million times
over the 30 years Tracy's
um plethora of problems here in case you
got inflammation in your body one doctor
might diagnose it as as things like
lupus or fibromyalgia and other doctors
are going to say oh you you have a joint
pain you got arthritis she has
osteopenia which is kind of early
osteoporosis you got degenerative disc
disease
and she's got thyroid low thyroid issues
and so what kind of diet would you put
her on a gluten-free diet of course yeah
and then what would you do to help that
thyroid what what would you do about her
diet
well she can't eat because it feels
vegetables yeah no Cruise Shivers
vegetables what makes up that category
cruciferous vegetables like kale and
cabbage and
stuff like that broccoli and Brussels
sprouts and that kind of stuff yeah I
apologize an airplane flying right over
okay
okay at any rate that's not me grinding
my teeth that's an airplane's land over
and she weighs 144 pounds and so what
would you give her to deal with all this
musculoskeletal stuff including the pain
and the thyroid
well for her issues I would suggest that
she gets on one healthy Bone and Joint
pack and adds to it uh MSM
pro-joint vitamin D3 for absorption and
of course the CM cream comes with that
and um
and also Ocean's gold
okay actually Ocean's gold for the
thyroid so Char is correct Tracy you
want to get one of the healthy boner
joint packs I would get an extra bottle
of the Osteo so you could take two doses
of that a day
I would also get the MSM one bottle of
that so you can take three of those MSM
tablets twice a day they're designed to
support and promote mange repair
cartilage ligaments tendons connective
tissue here it comes discs between
invertebrate bone makes bone itself
there will be a a bottle of the glucogel
with the healthy bone joint pack so you
can just take five of those a day okay
you divide them up three in the morning
with breakfast until dinner time kind of
thing you can even get another bottle
and take five three times a day if you
want to speed things up and then there's
a CM cream that comes with the healthy
Bone and Joint pack
and
um what would you do Charmaine
um was that CM cream oh vitamin D3 you
said that vitamin D3 three of those
twice a day that's two bottles a month
and um so let's let's go those
directions and stay away from all the
bad stuff the fried foods that protests
Meats all the gluten to maximize
absorption and you're going to be one of
our testimonies so do call us uh every
two weeks uh two weeks four weeks six
weeks eight weeks because you're going
to get a great great response here you
might even grow a half inch or so
um because degenerative disc disease the
disc shrink the bourbon get closer
together you might even get some
um do you have any noise in your in your
ears you have any tinnitus ringing in
the ears or wishing sounds
uh maybe on occasion but not too much
I've been yeah recently I've been like
waking up uh with that vertigo feeling
dizzy like laying in bed I yeah
that's osteoporosis of the skull and
that'll all go away because this is all
just a simple nutritional deficiencies
obviously approach to the skull okay
stay away from the bad foods maximize
absorption and it'll be amazed at how
quickly your body will respond and you
shall see some benefit and this is very
typical we're just finishing up a book
here that just deals with the 25
diseases you get from osteoporosis of
the skull because it's so prevalent that
and you know uh your your general
practitioner might refer you to a
neurologist ear nose and throat doctor
an eye doctor a hearing doctor
um a neurologist all this sort of stuff
in a dentist of course and
it says really just honesty approaches
to the skull there's 12 pairs of cranial
nerves and as one of those things where
they will
um get squeezed coming through those
tunnels by the bone matrix which is kind
of like the rebar the bone which ramps
up when you have osteoporosis your bone
wants to sound to try and stay strong
when you're losing the minerals
and so
um you're going to be amazed uh
literally there are thousands and
thousands of people who are misdiagnosed
and mistreated both
when they have osteoporosis of the skull
uh it's just a mess and so we were
obligated to write this book so we can
save America
from the skull down okay so give us the
others call every couple of weeks Tracy
because you're going to be a great
testimony okay Doug we have time to
start another one yeah let's get one
going let's head back to Minnesota and
Lucille you're on with Dr Wallach
Lucille you're on the air
thank you for taking my call and I'm
just calling you about my son um James
who has schizophrenia and I do have
another question if we have time if it's
okay with you
okay let's get get with James how old is
he what does he weigh
um he's 31 he weighs about 245 pounds
how tall is he okay
and did he have autism as a kid or 80d
or ADHD anything like that not that I
know of
okay does he have any other issues how
about pressure diabetes arthritis
no he's very healthy
okay
he kept a lot of feelings yeah yeah is
he is he on medication
is he's been on for 13 years
okay is he on any other medication again
how about pressure diabetes anything
like that
not yet okay okay all right all right
Charmaine we only have a minute here
before we go to the break so we'll get
started here with Lucille's son James
and
um 245 pounds six foot three yeah he's
if it's all muscle that's great and he
may be 20 pounds overweight otherwise
um but what would you do for this guy
diet wise
well I'd get him on a gluten-free diet
for sure just for the heck of it because
yeah gluten-free diet no sugar none of
the bad stuff fried foods processed meat
sauce and glutans get your pen and paper
ready Lucille because we're going to
come back and give your son James a
program or brain and mental issues after
these
it's some information
you're listening to Dead Doctors Don't
Lie on the zbs radio network with your
host Dr Joel Wallach
[Music]
if you're the type of person who likes
to volunteer and help others this should
interest you what better way to help
people than to help them with improved
Health youngevity has been helping
people promote Optimal Health among
others for decades our approach to
health is drastically different than
medical doctors who mostly only treat
symptoms as a veterinarian Dr Joel
Wallach discovered that many common
disease states are actually preventable
and reversible our mission is to help
people achieve overall health and
wellness and to help educate others to
achieve Optimal Wellness as well and
here's the best part while helping
people with their health and wellness
you'll also be able to build your very
own home-based business
for more information contact your local
youngevity associate and don't forget to
ask about the home-based business
opportunity the antioxidants found in
bitty fruits and vegetables are known to
help support and promote good health
research has also shown that dark
chocolate once known as the food of the
Gods is rich in healthy nutrients in
fact dark chocolate is higher in
antioxidant content than any other food
youngevity has combined a proprietary
blend of velvety rich dark chocolate
with whole fruit pulp and whole fruit
juice extracts from mangosteen Goji or
wolfberry acai berry and Cherry along
with vitamins and minerals producing a
smooth Rich delectable concentrate
called cocogeevity it tastes so great I
sometimes drink it right out of the
bottle or pour it over ice cream
cocogeevity is highly bioavailable
meaning your body will absorb and make
use of all of these healthy nutrients if
you'd like to learn more about
nutritional supplementation call your
local youngevity associate and don't
forget to ask about home-based business
opportunities
you've listed a physician and
veterinarian Dr Joel Wallach helped many
people on the Dead Doctors Don't Buy
talk radio program you've also heard
hundreds of people tell how Dr Wallach
and youngevity products have changed
their lives if you're now convinced that
Dr Wallach is on to something and you
want to try youngevity's premium quality
products for yourself we can connect you
with a distributor that serves your
local area simply call our special
helpline voicemail at
313-444-3463 that's
313-444-3463 call right now and leave
your name telephone number or email
address and we'll see to it that the
right person contacts you shortly
remember the phone number
313-444-3463 that's
313-444-3463 call now to change your
life that's 313-444-3463
oh yeah
we're back with Dead Doctors Don't line
the CBS radio network Dr Joel Wallach
here if you enjoy Crusade and Douglas go
right back to Minnesota and Lucille
Charmaine you there I'm here okay uh
what would you do for her son um
James who's had for 13 years he's been
diagnosed with schizophrenia he's got
this this um issue okay and so would you
do for him well first thing he needs to
do is get on a gluten-free diet no oils
no fried foods and no restrictions we
say no sugar no sugar yep and then for
his issues I would get him on two
healthy brain and heart packs daily
ultimate daily classic distressed
synaptive
and um go from there yeah it wouldn't
hurt I'd give him an extra bottle of
minerals a month so he can take another
ounce uh two ounces of the plain
minerals in the middle of the day uh
could be the plain unflavored minerals
it could be the I wouldn't give them the
Cherry mens but I would uh also offer
them the strawberry kiwi which is very
very low in sugar but it has the 78
minerals in there there's and I would
get a hair analysis on him Lucille
I get a hair analysis on him
um because I want to see there's a
couple of specific nutrients
that when you're deficient in them it
causes these types of problems including
schizophrenia and and behavioral
problems of all kinds you know the whole
Spectrum and so it'll be good for him
because you're not going to be around
forever I'm not going to be around
forever so we need to make sure he's
okay after you're gone and so you're not
there to watch him or help him support
him and so
um I I'd get a hold of that book rare
Earthman cures go to you know read the
whole thing then because they're chapter
four five and six chapters four five and
six goes into these behaviors and then
you want to get to um chapter 11 learn
how to collect the hair
how to box it up or to ship it two two
three weeks later you get the results
back and then give us a call when you
get the results back because I want to
ask you about specific nutrients but I
don't want to do that until you get the
hair analysis because I don't want to
um sort of cloud the water you know by
telling you something until until you
get the hair analysis done but um yeah
this we can we can prevent schizophrenia
bipolar depression make depression we
can we can prevent and reverse things
like um
autism ADD ADHD I did it myself when I
was nine years old accidentally I mean
even without even knowing what I was
doing I was just trying my parents had
taken me to see 20 doctors over a period
of five years because I had what would
be called Tourette's Syndrome today
which is a variation of of autism and I
was getting pretty violent okay and they
wanted to institutionalize me put me in
an institution for the rest of my life
because of my behavior and which is
probably
you know good because it alerted me that
they weren't going to be able to help me
20 doctors couldn't help me and so I
started eating animal food and in three
days time I cured myself
after 20 doctors had looked at me
and raised their hands up and said we
don't know what he's got because he
didn't even have a name for it back then
okay but these things when you when you
read that book chapters four five and
six and chapter 11 it will blow your
mind how much we know it's just really
too bad that the psychiatrists and
psychologists they just wanted to talk
therapy and prescribe drugs as opposed
to doing a hair analysis which would
give you a clue of what to give these
kids and turn around and save them and
their families a lot of unnecessary
grief
a lot of unnecessary misery okay well I
want to uh
um see here make sure and Shar
P people with emotional problems over
the years you've been working with me
for almost 30 years and you've seen
these things before
oh yeah we got people in our group that
got kids that won't go without the
synaptive they they need it
you know and people that have been in
the service and you know over in Vietnam
and PTSD yep yep and
and that really improves their quality
of life
yeah nobody's ever died from overdoses
of vitamins no no no no no no no and
it's not prescription and so they can
deal with this themselves they can
adjust things
um and um you know there's variations on
this so uh they can match their budget
appropriately and so we're very excited
that Lucille asked us about this and we
appreciate Lucille if you would contact
us
um every couple of weeks and let us know
how your son is doing and if he's moved
you know say six eight weeks Ten Weeks
down the line and he's moved and want to
say something we'd love to hear from him
too because oh he'll have a wonderful
testimony thank you so much Char super
super jump as usual thank you so much
Doug and Sam superlative time as usual
God bless each and every one of you God
bless our troops God bless the national
anthem God bless the American flag and
God bless America
[Music]
foreign